hi I'm Matt Welch for recent TV I'm here
at Freedom Fest in Las Vegas and I'm
honored to be joined by Matt kibbe old
friend of recent CEO Freedom Works Matt
thanks for joining us great to be here
2013's been kind of libertarian
Christmas since about February when Rand
Paul first did this filibuster and we've
seen a series of scandals the IRS NSA
your group dia slow the Tea Party you
kind of have an ear to the ground more
than most people has like NSA an anti
security state thing has that started to
animate a tea party that started out
more as as a reaction to big government
spending in Obamacare yeah I really
think it's sort of closed the circle
with you know what I call IRS voter
suppression of the Tea Party and the way
they hassled anybody trying to get 501 C
4 status the implementation of Obamacare
and the database hub whether they're
pulling in all of our personal health
care data our financial data and all of
this national security data the the seal
on that is this NSA stuff and I did a
press conference with Rand Paul a couple
weeks ago where Lois Go Mart and the
ACLU and standing next to each other
very uncomfortable moment but I think
that's this new position we're in it's
not really about Republican versus
Democrat anymore and I think I think our
issues the libertarian values are now
this is our moment this is our chance to
actually redefine the conversation is
that sort of bipartisan civil liberties
coalition is it on the grow is it
sizeable yet is there anything to to be
optimistic about without it you know
it's kind of surprising how few
Democrats and I would say the same thing
about Republicans it's a minority in
both caucuses inside the system but I
think it's really about the the insiders
being nervous that we're actually gonna
find them out we're gonna find out all
the things that that they've been doing
to violate our basic rights and it's got
to be the outsiders meeting the insiders
and that's of course that is that the
Tea Party mantra that we have to take
back our government we have to take back
the system from the insiders I think
it's going to trend that way because
we're gonna use the same tactics
same tools same data same social media
that they're using to snoop on us to to
open up the system so everybody knows
what's going on
where are the battlegrounds right now
what are the next couple of flights on
your immediate horizon where this kind
of establishment versus the insurgent
where is that coming up next well I
think it's it's it's the IRS hearings
are going to continue the investigations
are going to continue and there's too
many victims to bury that and that's
going to continue to dog the Democrats
this whole question of the NSA it's
growing they want to talk about Edward
Snowden but the civil liberties issues
there are much bigger
they're quite bipartisan it's going to
go straight to the election and the
implementation of Obamacare you've
already seen Obama arbitrarily say you
know what I'm not going to enforce my
own law we're gonna have a conversation
about that but there's all of these
deadlines they're all time bombs where
people are going to discover that the
promises made during the health care
debate we're all lies we're gonna
discover who's paying what who's not
going to get what they were promised and
who gets hurt 2010 was sort of a tea
party election we now have a thing that
called the Liberty movement which kind
of didn't exist in Capitol Hill
certainly before what do you foresee the
2014 elections for I think that
particularly when you talk to young
people at the Tea Party is evolving and
at some point it probably doesn't even
maintain that brand anymore because it's
broader I like to call it a Liberty
movement maybe that's a clumsy term but
we got to come up with something but
there's this beautiful mashup of Tea
Partiers Ron Paul Millennials and and
even young conservatives who are far
more libertarian than than their elders
when it comes to issues like civil
liberties that's the movement now and
our champions in the Senate in the house
Justin Amash David Schweikert in house
my clear and Paul and I would add Ted
Cruz to that he's not quite as
libertarian they're taken things over we
have a seat at the table on the inside
that's energizing people on the outside
2014 could be that moment that this
coalition emerges in force it's very
great thanks for the update Matt kibbe
for recent TV I am at well